they were talk about building a video
editing PC also just I haven't said a
good video editing PC it's the generally
good gaming PC so two birds with one
stone in this video guys but I think
this might be the most helpful thing if
you're looking to build a computer for
filmmaking it's just a basic price break
down the price point stays the same and
what you get for it just constantly goes
up about two years from now each of
those parts is probably going to cost
the same amount it's just they're each
going to be way better how much should
you spend on your CPU probably around
$500 once you start spending more than
that you're starting to hit diminishing
returns spend another fifty two hundred
dollars on a cooling solution for the
CPU and you can then overclock and CPU
and get $2,000 performance how much do
you spend on the motherboard probably
around three to four hundred dollars
you'll make sure you get high quality
components and the right number of ports
that you need GPU how much should you
spend on a GPU try to spend about five
hundred dollars maybe more I'm just
spending more than a thousand dollars
energy pu once again you're hitting the
wall diminishing returns you can look
into the Titans which are more the
workstation type graphics cards and you
got the money and you're a working
professional certainly investigate power
supply about a hundred bucks or so ram
probably wanna spend about two hundred
to three hundred dollars on ram that
should get you about thirty two
gigabytes nice fast ram finally hard
drives hard drives are always kind of a
moving target so I'll just say this I
would recommend buying two rather than
one cell estate drive ludicrous speed go
and if you have your eyes pork someone
on a 512 gigabyte solid state drive
think about getting to 256 is instead
you'll generally come in around the same
price point but you'll get twice as fast
performance just footage storage hard
drives
I mean prices are always varying on
those things you know spend about 150
bucks on one of those and you'll get
four terabytes these days and it'll you
should be a quality hard drive so yeah
wait four terabytes 150 bucks is that
how much it is now man it's so cheap
Oh cases Oh get a good case get a really
really good case drop like the 100 to
200 dollars it takes to get a really
good case yeah you will not regret it
it's one of the best things you can do
for your computer good cases have a
couple things going for them they help
have a bunch of flight extra ports and
all that stuff for both USB audio things
like that things you can plug into your
motherboard make it easier to use in
general you also get great features such
as things like this hard drive bays in
the front Wow so you can have hot
swapping hard drives if you look up here
there's a volume knob a so really enough
of you seriously what is this for it's a
volume knob because s is FC on it yeah
for a phone control in the of FM for
when you want to are in the radio
technically a joke alright okay if you
don't have that in your budget that's
fine you start looking at those
components we talked about and just keep
stuffing them down little by little but
keep in mind that your CPU has priority
in terms of what you need to spend your
money on followed by your RAM you have
make sure you have a plenty of RAM and
your GPU beyond that becomes less and
less important what you have in your
computer so that covers the computer
some other things to think about getting
a nice monitor definitely helps we tend
to stick with 1080p monitors good color
representation goes a long way
good eyes keyboard good nice Mouse etc
but those are all components the end of
the day it's what's in here that matters
right yeah it's what's in here that
matters so there's a little overview of
what to look for in a video editing PC
versus a gaming PC let's get specific
here so here we have an Origin PC this
is one of our fastest computers in the
office
um previously we had these r2d2 suite
r2d2 computers
that we built as a part of Wayne Boyd
yeah land party back in the day still
running great but this right now this is
the beast to be let's take a look inside
this box talk about the components oh
you should look for it building your own
video editing or possibly gaming pc
multi-purpose doesn't really matter
let's kind of take a part let's take a
look let's take a look oh that doesn't
tell me anything how you open this wait
okay
I thought there's supposed to be memory
in here I'm going there buddy
Sam's a kid that all right his old
neighborhood hired to take the viruses
off the computer back in the day yeah I
use a bottle of disinfectant
sar from the top CPUs basically have two
choices these days Intel and AMD
generally speaking you want to say with
Intel over AMD when it comes to
processors for video editing rig Intel
processor is simply a litte faster and a
little bit better integrated into things
like Adobe Premiere now the thing is if
you're on a budget you don't need to buy
the top of line CPU a fast CPU
definitely helps when it comes to video
editing we're smart we save their money
and we overclock them to a higher speed
rather than buying a higher speed CPU
come here and you take a look at the
computer here's what the processor sits
here we have liquid cooling you don't
need a huge processor to run video games
however when it comes to video editing
CPUs are exceptionally good for when you
are actually rendering videos out and
when you're actually working in like a
program like After Effects or 3d program
and you're basically trying to take
these graphics you see on screen and
render them into a file that's generally
where the CPU comes in most mm-hmm the
reason gaming pcs don't need so much RAM
you're mostly loading in your graphics
card dummy think you see a lot of the
game elements don't actually take up
that much memory they're all made to
usually be pretty lightweight because
they need to go onto the memory of the
GPU long story short if you've ever seen
a long complicated video editing
timeline with tons of clips and all this
stuff and all these things in this huge
timeline super complicated looking you
find that it very quickly gets leggy and
if you have all these sequences and
windows and stuff open you are sucking
up your RAM so
all so fast so that's why having a lot
of RAM will help you with video editing
how much RAM is enough ram answer 32
gigabytes let's talk about the next big
thing that we like to talk about GPUs
GPUs what are they graphics processor
unit maybe look at this this is GPU in
here this is an NVIDIA GeForce Titan
black what can I say other than it's the
most expensive GPU you can get so
alright so if you guys are looking for a
GPU for your film computer once again we
recommend doing Nvidia over AMD let's
just say we have one computer with the
name deep processor graphics card and
it's the one that everyone hates to use
now NVIDIA has CUDA which is a little
bit better a little bit faster and a
little bit more supportive than OpenGL
what's Gouda CUDA is basically a
programming language that GPUs can
decode normal programming language needs
to run on the CPU when you have this
basically a whole nother computer
sitting inside your computer known as
the GPU it has a memory it has this one
processor has its own motherboard it's a
whole other computer sitting inside a
computer it's made for just crunching
numbers generally those numbers equal
explosions and first-person view
gunfights in this case we're gonna have
them equal footage and footage effects
and green screen keys and size
translations and animations and all that
kind of stuff a lot of gaming GPUs will
have one two maybe four gigabytes of
memory you want something with four
gigabytes or higher of memory for video
editing if possible another thing to
talk about is what GPU to get right now
we could talk about exactly what GPU to
buy but in one year that will change but
we'll say it anyways right now he's
probably at a 980 that's what you want
to look for if you're getting a nice GPU
you look into Titans but if you want a
lot of bang for your buck the 98 is kind
of the way to go there's a very specific
reason we have these huge graphics cards
in these computers and that isn't
because we like to play elite dangerous
with like 4x subsampling or whatever
super sampling it's because we actually
like to watch our 6k footage that we
shoot on our Reds so if you're not
shooting on the red if you're not
shooting 4k 5k 6k footage you maybe
don't have to worry about going so
high-end maybe look at the higher-end
GPUs from a generation or two back like
the 7 80s for example something else to
think about for a filmmaking computer
is data storage so you have footage
footage takes up a lot of space using
more space in games we usually clear
around 100 gigabytes 120 gigabytes are
so footage each day that we shoot
frequently more if you have a game
installed on a solid-state drive versus
on a regular hard drive you've seen the
speed difference you get when loading
that game same thing for film computers
when you're loading a project files at a
vast amounts of footage fast nice fat
pipe for a hard drive really gets your
project open and running quickly fat
pipes now we have solid-state drives in
fact to solid state to solid state
drives rated together in raid zero
formation what does that mean basically
the computer treats those two drives as
one and you effectively double your data
bandwidth not too shabby
however we don't keep any footage on
that drive that drive runs our operating
system it runs our program files in a
lot of our caches that store like image
data and that kind of stuff so that's
all real fast in and out of the computer
but the footage that we have is stored
on just a regular platter hard drive and
you want them to be decently fast we're
using Western Digital blacks but
basically at the end of the day you're
looking for a solid-state drive or two
in a raid zero configuration to run your
operating system and programs as well as
the store your image caches and you want
to have just regular large hard drives
for storing your footage and have a
second one for backup for that footage I
feel like we should talk about wire
management for a moment here so I was
talking about heat and all this kind of
stuff one of the best ways you can get
your computer to run cool is to not have
a big mess of wire sitting inside your
computer so I'm here take it out take a
look what professional cable management
looks like this is this is Origen
handiwork at work here and then all the
cables bubbled up going back into these
holes here see there you go they're all
organized on the other side here just
out of your view without cluttering up
the space this is known as cable
management and there's something you can
do yourself in building your own
computer not to mention having great
cable management inside your computer
allows you to be a little bit more
relaxed when it comes to the cables out
point point taken right there boom let's
talk about the mobo Lobo and motherboard
a gaming PC may not have the most robust
motherboard per gaming PC just need
something that can kind of hold the GPU
and the CPU and have a couple USB ports
and you're good but for a video editing
PC it's not quite the case generally
we're doing video editing you're doing a
lot of unique specialized tasks that's
we're just generally buying a higher-end
motherboard we'll make all those little
components run a little bit faster a
little bit smoother and a little bit
more reliably because you also end up
generating a lot of heat and a high-end
computer not to mention a good
motherboard has a ton of ports if you're
going to take a peek at the backs of any
of the computers in here you notice that
there are dozens of things coming in and
out of them and that's absolutely
necessary for good video editing rig
here's the things to look for in a
filmmaking computer month would you want
lots of ports USB 3.0 ports really solid
USB buses eSATA ports potentially maybe
a firewire port if you have to deal with
older camera tech and it's not hard for
somebody to put out $150 motherboard and
say that it runs a CPU and some memory
just fine and it will but when things
start to be on for 12 hours straight
rendering things will heat up things
will kind of warp a little bit sometimes
because of the heat so when you pay that
a little bit of extra money all the
components are just a little bit better
and you're less likely to discover your
computer sitting in a little bowl of
flame never happened that you never had
that sounds really funny because never
would love to see that there you go
kinda like a computer caught fire what
happens dude he's editing 12k footage
was insane um so that's the biggest
difference between gaming PC and a film
editing rig is gaming PC's it's okay for
them to blow up because likely your save
file is in the cloud somewhere yeah your
whole video project is not one thing
that everyone always forgets about when
it comes to anything filmmaking related
is audio and sound everyone forgets to
talk about it everyone's like oh my God
look how many K's I got they forget that
they want some good sound in there dang
video too so when it comes to audio on a
computer like this each motherboard
usually has a microphone input and an
audio output but realistically you're
going to want to consider getting an
external audio interface for a good film
editing computer an external audio
interface will
to do much more advanced things that a
typical computer or motherboard cannot
such as using XLR cables and actual
microphones this is great for when
you're doing voiceover or ADR or need to
take that super sweet fancy microphone
you have on your camera and plug it into
your computer instead I would personally
recommend a Focusrite sound it's great
employment next up we'll just really
touch upon power supplies you don't need
a bajillion watts but you do enough
wattage to cover the computer you
basically just leave one that has good
connections on it so it has all the
right connections for the computer but
which most of them do these days you're
probably gonna want a power supply with
about 750 watts if you're gonna run two
graphics cards that's a different story
yeah if you're running two graphics
cards you probably don't need much of
the information in this video so last
but not least it would be remiss of me
to talk about computers and video
editing computers without actually
talking about origin PC so this is a
computer from origin PC you can either
build your own computer which is great
highly recommended so you can learn how
to build a computer than what goes
inside your machine that you are relying
on for your work but if you don't have
the time or want somebody else to do it
as a professional how their commend
checking out origin PC go pay a nominal
fee for somebody else to put your system
together they will overclock it for you
they will do all the cable management
thanks to origin for hooking us up with
a sweet computer and yep I highly
recommend it if you guys are looking for
something to build a computer for you